we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p let's take a
listen to this voicemail that came in I
gave you mentioned two reasons like
might be okay to kill a bear for to
sustain a village for food right war for
population control yeah but what about
what Betty Duvall said if it's attacking
a schoolhouse full of children
that's self-defense right is that okay
they don't know yeah I guess I have to
amend my prior comments which is you can
make an argument for hunting bears if it
is for subsist subsistence there are
questions about hunting animals when
there is a quote overpopulation problem
that I think is a sort of debate that
can be had but yeah of course how could
I forget Betsy DeVos is comment that
schools might come under attack by
grizzly bears and in that case you'd
have to shoot him yeah I don't really
think that's in the nature of grizzly
bears though to just unprovoked charge
at a group of students mmm or like go
into a high school I guess I don't know
I mean they're very flat ribbon you hear
about it campgrounds you often see bears
show up and I think that mostly they get
violent because they get scared I don't
know they're necessarily targeting
people but maybe I'm wrong maybe grizzly
bears are targeting people and I just
don't know about it we've got a
fantastic bonus show for you today we'll
talk about a viral video showing the
propaganda and disinformation that's
going on as coming out of Sinclair owned
TV stations we'll talk about making your
blood deadly to mosquitoes I know a lot
of people who would love that we'll also
talk about an outbreak related to
synthetic marijuana all of those stories
and more on the bonus show get access at
david pakman.com slash membership or by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show